une production du studio sfr
est venu ou sans filtre le podcast on
parle ce qu'on veut nous inviter dates
ci dessus ph quentin avec moi doom
planque et cette semaine c'est un
épisode sponsorisé par revis vivre qui
vous offre 1 30% de rabais vous j'ai
bien dit 30% de rabais en utilisant le
code sans filtre podcast 30 justement
d'un banc de vie
est aujourd'hui on le rencontre et
d'hommes 2000 et qu'il est un des
cofondateurs lui et kehl et sa conjointe
claudia qui ont fondé vivre puis de
raconter toute son histoire en fait tout
pour quoi ils ont commencé ce qu'est ce
qui s'est passé quand au début on était
deux heures parce juste les 2 à couper
les cubes à la main vraiment une
histoire spar inspirante cécile c'est
l'fun de voir derrière aussi les marques
que vous connaissez que vous aimez qui
l'on doit aussi commencer podcast puis
de voir c'est quoi le parcours une main
derrière c'était quoi les étapes aussi
pour devenir ce que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est super intéressant nous évidemment
s'intéresse à l'entrepreneuriat comme un
petit espoir intéressant de voir les
étapes il élimine move qui ont été faits
pour que ça devienne ce que c'est devenu
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment juste
inspirant de voir que c'est un couple
avec des bonnes valeurs qui voulait
justement promouvoir le bien être la
santé des bons aliments bien manger mais
de manière quand même rapide de manière
abordable aussi
paquet chapeau un vélib c'est un grand
plaisir à s'entraîner avec dom c'est
toujours tellement hâte de rencontrer
l'humain derrière la compagnie
vraiment une belle conversation fait qu
encore une fois sans filtre pas de casse
30 pour prendre pour sandra pêcheurs
vivent sur des latitudes tester leurs
produits puis après la conversation vous
allez vous allez les aimait tellement
vous allez vouloir vous en procurer fait
que bombe à castres monaco
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
dominique
demers m tout droit venu de sherbrooke
qui s
est
rendue avant tout mon temps on a amené
ici cinq ans dans l'ouest puis avec les
cowboys on dit on a plus besoin d'aller
au bureau chaque jour à qui on a on a
acheté en estrie qui est fait que le
jury a une face au nahd qui vous venez
de ces deux régions le top 8 à blondeau
quand tu dis on c'est octobre wells
jeudi un point qui fait quand on a tout
le temps avec la charraud qu'on est venu
à montréal partir et vivre pendant cinq
ans pile on est de retour aux sources y
avait fixé son sac et maintenant avec le
télétravail vous a plus besoin d'être à
montréal depuis nécessité est ce que
vous venez souvent quand même ou même
pas être humain quand même temps que le
critère grippe lors de l'interruption
c'est vraiment rapidement s'est rendu
compte qu'il y aurait pas de du niveau
auquel on retournerais cinq jours bureau
comme arabes et islamiques de travail où
tout le monde doit être bureau cinq
jours semaine mais elle mondiale est
quand même c'était jusqu'à demain c'est
juste la façon que le monde travaille et
puis on se rend compte que ça revienne
jamais comme seulement nous commençons
mais n'a pris qu'à la gaspésie une
enquête allait
maintenant sa concision ça veut dire
qu'on ses potes ça va être quoi mais ça
se passe très chaud faqs qu'ils avaient
encore un bureau oui oui je sais pas
loin d'ici ok puis vous avez combien
demande le maintenant on va retourner au
début tu combien de monde en ce moment
on est soixante employés un pion vent
parle un peu mais c'est tout des
employés qui travaillent au bureau fait
que la production se fait avec
département qui fait que les 60
personnes c'est en vente marketing
service client comptabilité mais quand
tu parles de ton employé qui est allé en
gaspésie le être encore le abbaoui il ou
elle pique sa vie va être là maintenant
pouvoir travailler avec vive mais dans
les régions exact pour moi ça apparaît
tellement comme
[Musique]
une
solution à l'année d'avant il était
juste je veux remplir les régions
maintenant le si les entreprises peuvent
se décentraliser des gros centres
urbains pouvoir envoyer leurs employés
jeune dynamique dans les régions ça
m'apparaît comme la meilleure solution
parce que tu contribues à des
entreprises québécoises mais aussi à ton
économie locale de thé région puis je
trouve que le retour en région c'est
vraiment quelque chose moi ça me parle
beaucoup le nôtre que puis tu viens tu
la région ben moi je viens du saguenay
acquis sauf que ces mots mettons le
retour aux sources et plus comme de leur
tournée mondiale en sortons à québec
mais un temps continent ce qu'on fait
ici c'est possible 100 % à petit une
affaire nous on monte dix par table son
nom pour ajuster les salaires on n'a pas
donné de salaire de qui était pas de
montréal fakty tu te retrouves à brive
en gaspésie oui elle a pu s'acheter une
support de votre maison sur le bord de
l'autre c'est un set up drive le puits à
travailler à distance où ça va super
bien fait que fait pitié on était
structurée nous chez vivent avec quelque
chose qu'on avait déjà mis en place qui
était à chaque trimestre tout le monde
fly haine que tu habites à toronto aux
états unis tout le monde vient à
montréal puis on en ghetto guédelon
parle stratégie on part résultat on a
des barbecues tout ensemble puis quatre
fois par année fait qu' on était comme
un petit peu déjà stoppé pour ce genre
nival puis ça fait juste permettre de de
se voir en personne concernée c'est
lorsque tu es
le télétravail reviendrait of realtors
la prime et c'est en partant là dessus
c'est à ce moment justement
c'est très pratique puis les beaucoup
d'entreprises qui font et qui sait sa
salle en même temps de nouveaux
avantages qui même pour les îles gens
qui travaillent pour la conciliation
travail-famille tcc mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est en ce moment
mettons-y tout le monde encore une
mémoire du moment où ce que tout le
monde allait travailler au bureau chez
vif tout le monde connaît
personnellement mais on dirait que
je projetais à long terme qu'est ce que
ça va devenir les entreprises vont être
c'est que jamais dont malik n'a jamais
rencontré en personne ou ti ci contre
est que le lien est plus
difficile la question des coûts de
nouveaux employés qui ont juste mais
quand jamais vu personne c'est lé
sentiment d'appartenance c'est important
pittis à contribuer à vous faites
étaient des méta jo de vouloir
travailler ni des tipis le fait
justement d'aller sur place puis de
rencontrer les humains changer un peu
autour de la machine à café dessus ça
fait partie aussi dit ce qui unit comme
une compagnie est ce que c'est quelque
chose que la culture passe quelque chose
qui vous inquiète ou qui c'est sûr mais
le baril qu
on
les a que tu sois personnes mais non
c'est un bon point puis on des affaires
que moi j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qu'on a le
plus perdu du nom présentiel c'est
toutes les branches sont créatifs je
pose les bonnes pratiques sur un écran
mais c'est vraiment une idée d une rétro
tanapo le monte entre mi-août les bandes
things d d'idées c'est vraiment petit on
essaie de ramener ce dans les foires
le cathéter d'une telle homes et des
polices il a qui quand tu es dans la
même pièce vite jeté le talent et
l'autre qui tu écris il répond impuretés
c'est comme la concentration est plus
diffuse un peu quand même comme les
justes les fois qu'on a fait le plus
progresser le studio cet égard dans la
partie où est-ce qu'on était les deux
ans pour venir se promener dans le salon
en leur
nom et alphonse et six classes
j'avoue je me vis à vis avec ça avec son
penchant fait revivre ça fait combien de
temps l'excellence et ça va bien que ça
fait 6 md quelqu'un mort et qui est un
piti les premiers en étions sortis de
l'école dans certaines universités mois
puis claudio fac c'est peut-être la
première année le steve vraiment pour
une entreprise dans sa soute et on
essayait des enfants sorties de
les collants quoi moi j'ai fait d'une
mécanique à nuire si de chabrol puis
cody à la fête disco éducation city qui
sortis ensemble à ce moment là c est
quand même temps ça fait 12 ans qu'on
était qu'aucun lieu aucun
on n'a pas de parents trop prendre comme
tel on savait pas qu'on voulait voir une
entreprise comme
ce qui se passe
là dedans année de génie à chabot pour
faire un projet ouais on travaille tout
par une équipe de 6 pi il faut faire un
projet plus nous on avait fait un projet
dans le medicare puis je croyais
vraiment plutôt commun et peut-être
moyen de commercialiser ses hôtes et
c'est là que le premier ce poids que
dirais tu si je propre parti en enfer
après mon bac comme eu lieu de terminer
on a eu l'idée
de faire des scouts youtube parce que
dieu se faisait trois-quatre ans
qu'était viguen à ce moment là chaque
matin en faisant ce multisupport
compliquée avec toutes les
supérettes
des grandes rampes et au venin à jay kay
dans ton scoot il était vraiment
chaque matin on s'est rendu compte que
c'était vraiment pas accessible pour
ceux qui mènent aux autres marchés sans
donner le fuel qu'on a besoin pour
dimensionner puis à ce moment là on
avait un coup leur compte tenir ces
puits lui le matin c'était jean tools
inverse il se levait y ramasser une
barre granola quaker ont pu le vivre
parce que cinq secondes puis ils partent
eux partent à l'école puis on a comme on
voyait qu'à planter comme tout imagine
tu peux mettre cette nutrition lendemain
de monde qui ont pas le temps qu'ils
savent pas qu'ils veulent pas mettre
l'énergie laquelle on s'est dit on va
les faire en cube la veille comme seul
matin mais nous qui nous à l'erreur
juste pour vous aurait dit c'est ce que
le pape dans ton poma centre ajoute de
l'eau du port au travail ne pas mettre
plus de temps du chef de musique comme
j'ai fait je t'avais quand je me rends
tous ce matin je participe
fait que on a fait ça pour nous pour le
moment autour de nous à la mission de
page facebook on a comme lui un petit
peu de traction on a eu une publication
dans un journal locaux mais vous autres
vous le faisiez pour vous que les
approches de vous mais dans le sens vous
lie à ce moment l'homme et on voulait
vendre du rêve de fusionner sans parler
le long à tacoma ont trouvé le discours
bonnes dents puis 2 2 on voulait vont
pleuvoir hiatus eu un potentiel du jeu
tu installes à ce moment là le mot
plutôt on est un stade où on commence à
penser à l'idée d'avoir une entreprise
on s'est passé quoi vont être prises
c'est parce que tu entreprends lancés
pour que mon métier mais on est comme on
est curieux on explore chaque nuit on
dit que vous avez des jobs barre à damas
moi ça fait à ce moment là trois quatre
mois que j'ai fini mon bac pis le chu
dans un espèce de zone
je peux pas tout ce que j'ai fait de ma
silhouette à la
fac on lançait dans le monde on essaie
de voir si ça ça résonne avec les gens
de sherbrooke ping de fait on a quand
même vraiment bonnes réponses
moi par mon contenu puis on s'embarque
4dans pierre monnet ça devient projet
fuglsang et vous les faites vous même
dans le fond chez vous laisse l'outil
qu'il vous allez livrer sainement
comment ça se passait tellement quatre
siècles explique pis
dans l'est les cube ont découpé à main
avec un gros couteau parce qu'on n'avait
pas vu que mon genou droit c'était juste
des tubes coupé à la main qu'un gros
couteau fait que mon geste je lai
décelable de smoothie pas fond sur une
plaque de cuisson mais trente mètres
coulton smoothie lâche semaines en congé
l'autre coupé avec un gros couteau je
veux tu as fait des tas de points
pour couper de la glace qui restent
solides la glace et de la
technique mais j'en ai coupés de la
plaque de
vous étiez pendant deux ans deux ans
ouais puis que je quitte à plonger dès
maintenant dans votre pays que le camp
vous faisiez ce chez vous le way combien
vous n'en fassiez mettons comme pour
combien de personnes combien de smoothie
vous faisiez par jour on est resté trois
mois face à chez nous sommes restés
comme un précipité la fin des trois mois
c'était combien
30 40 50 paquets par jour un show à
l'ailé livre et on les livre est hot
avec notes au total est de monsieur m'a
un peu d'épicerie à domicile puis après
ceux là on ne trouve un petit local
commercial à sherbrooke où les 20 plus
grands congélateurs mais c'est rien de
fou et notamment stijn s c'est le
batteur de cuisine jean la cuisine
restera mettront plus grande puis le on
était là pendant un an avec des employés
jugent aux autres je suis ok
je coupais les cubains
ces cas la décision mais ton j'imagine
que c'est dans les trois premiers mois
mais c'est quand même faire jack et
belle aux aguets ce qu'on va
s'incorporer et puis qu'on va devenir
une business là parce qu'au début
j'imagine que quand tu penses à des amis
puis à des proches et comment ils font
environnantes on compte à toi mais tu
fais belloche faut être une entreprise
je sais pas quand auxerre ou une coupe
de moyenne puis on how voir une société
en nom collectif genre est ce qu'on
voulait pas payer des frais des
corporations ces gens là décision dans
un peu nul quand tu commences la fac et
on sait partie de même ouvert un compte
on n'a pas tenté d affaires on n'avait
aucune idée de ce qu'on faisait le sait
mais là un sacrement faire c'est quand
aucune des les autres on le fait c'est
comme ce même poste que tu le fais parce
que tu le fais parce que tu sais qu'il
faut que je fasse deux coups elle s'est
même pas exactement qu'est ce tu fait
que ce parti boire
quelque chose qui marche i puis à ce
moment là car c'est juste vous deux
est-ce que c'était comme
est-ce que c'était quelque chose avec
lesquels vous pouvez gagner déjà votre
vie où vous vraiment propice à vélo
comme aucun sens
[Rires]
on perdait pas d'argent parce que je t
on il y avait maintenant de trois
médicaments contre fallait qu'ils
restent
dans tamara ce métier les rennais
j'avais à ces deux notions mathématiques
pour 4,6
soit pas
content
non ça marchait dans le sens où son père
n'est pas l'argent si on avait pas deux
de financement d'études pour la première
année c'était tout genre note je pense
qu'on avait mis dix mille pièces en tout
et pour tout ce qu elle avait été maire
que mon pour économies d'argent en
vendant son université firme était
capable de financer y avait dessus un
branding à ce moment là on a vu un bon
bah écoute les premiers brink's moi
j'avais appris photoshop parce que
fallait des années des affaires si pour
ce projet le ping l'eau était derrière
moi puis elle indique enfin que fait que
j'ai exécuté ce photoshop qui ont créé
nos packagings août puis ça nous a amené
tout ça on a fait la première 6 mois 1
an avec superman et on avait un ami
graphiste qui a fait rire le goût qui a
fait le premier package input ce ppi le
coup ont peu changé depuis que - le zoo
mais si vous saviez faisant ce qu'ils y
avait un plafond à cette manière de
travailler d'être juste les deux pays
que bah moi ça me rendait fou processus
d mon background utile le petit mutation
mais si j'ai étudié un gimmick années
quand même temps je me voyais que je ne
me voyais pas faire les cours d'eau
signifie casse les compagnies québec
alors ça sent l total appui joutes ont
tout autant il n'y reste ici ailleurs
que de couper des cubes à moi c'est ça
mais comme l'alternative ce jeu là je
l'avais pas parce que comme
il fallait lui fallait fallait fallait
des machines pas les autres appuis comme
on avait un lien de titres ou quatre
pièces de fait jeter un stade où je
voyais pas d'autre façon que de juste le
fait de mettre les autres le font amman
et on attend un plateau comme y en avait
juste plus de temps pour couper mais qui
fait que c'est comme fallait faire de
quoi puisque j'avais fait faire des
années de machine à gagner le voyagiste
points c'est ce que je vous ai fait une
machine pour couper les cubains en place
un espèce de grosse principe de matière
il écoute au 17 octobre puis on l'a fait
face a pris six mois ça va coûter 15 mai
de bias ça n'a jamais marché ostie ça
n'a jamais marché les couteaux péter
piste est l'enfant puis il y avait rien
qui existait déjà en fonctionnement ben
a retrospective
métier je sais ce qu'on voyait ton était
on était prêts m'approche la
piste et parce que pour régler le
problème direct que toi tu voyais qu'ils
étaient juste celui de couper les rues
mais c'est techniquement tron c'est
parce que la chaîne veut qu'à autre
chose qui se passe
fait qu'est ce qu'on a fait le requin
que c'est plus facile quand tu frappes
des mois comme ce que tous les mardis
dès qu'ils sortent ne tient qu on a eu
cette machine no 15 les pièces boulet
pour autrui est resté comme maggie si on
trouve points à l'avenue on arrête ses
piles on a eu l'idée de faire les
roulettes
parce qu'on s'est dit nos fonds c'est la
même façon et est pour tout le monde dit
qu'elle connaissait le bain ça
transforme en roumanie puis qui me fall
et roulette le béton comme encaisse
s'articuler concrètement mettons
pas faire d'enfant vous saisit à faire
avec ben mon enfance j'ai eu l'idée de
dire bien enfoncer n'y ait eu de couper
les clubs qui en plus de l'expérience
client était possible parce que quand
des feedbacks on avait cité
j'achète ton sac à l'épicerie l'a jamais
lâchée dans le ramener chez nous les
clubs sont déjà qu'on commentant le
chili en train de lire couper un coup
tous mon conte droite et cynthia plein
matin en france chaque et on savait
qu'on avait ce fait que la roulette
s'arrête mais comme tout ça qu'on me
remette un hectare de génie comme c'est
vraiment ce l'avenir des villes pilotes
le fait d annie la roulette dont le fait
sans l'humour on on on était mieux
installations malheur on avait un peu de
financement de ce fait qu'on a on a vu
certains équipements pour remplir les
couleurs les scellés puis on est parti
là dessus mais c'est c'est
moi mais ça me semble je me dis le tien
tu étais seul pendant deux ans du couple
et cube le titre diachylon passe à
l'autre état on s'achète une machine
quinze mille pièces d'investissement
sachy moi je vois pas comment
j'aurais réussi à mettons faire comme en
continuant ses trouvons une autre
solution magique qui c'est une somme
c'est un gros coup les j'imagine que
c'est ces moments là pour vous autres
autant
professionnellement que j'entends vous
dans votre vie sa devise c'est une épine
dans vos côtés en crise le jeu m'a dit
que cette salle va peut-être tort quand
même ces moments là avant d'arriver à
l'idée de comme la mettre en branle et
du genre une période de découragement
oui c'est ça c'est un médecin retrospect
ckt de date ça dure une éternité
retrospect un responsable peut-être un
second mais ça a sûrement d'une coupe de
semaine c'est le moment de com qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on aura tu peux discuter mais
non c'est des moments mais c'est ce qui
fait que ton
[Musique]
une belle entreprise je pense parce que
c'est comme si quotas qualité numéro un
je pensais que
mon pic lotus et la persévérance de qom
c'est quand tu arrives dans les moments
de joie comme la résilience la fameuse
réserve
un meurtre ou à trouver une solution
puis l'idée mettons initiale qui était
de prendre
vos habitudes alimentaires plus les
facilités pour pour les habitudes
alimentaires de votre colloque à
l'époque est-ce que c'était encore à ce
moment là les valeurs au sein de
l'entreprise qui sera encore sur la
mission c'était la méthode chez les gens
moins de rendre l'alimentation saine
comme on la voyait comme stéphane weiss
était bio sans gluten sans sucre ajouté
et on avait une coupe de deux on avait
aimé c'était quoi l'augmentation sienne
pour clos puis on voulait rendre ça que
c'est pour les gens avec si nous on
voulait pas faire un souci avec pièces
comme tu peux aller chercher au jazz
bharti a coaché voulons fait référence
aux outils qui va avoir les mains qui
témoignent plus quelqu'un d'intuitif que
je suis las vegas mais pour 3,4 pierre
militaires des challenges ou city parce
que on l'achète nos aïeux en bio coûtent
trois faucheurs
conventionnel il faut faire ça tout le
temps resté au centre de ce qu'on fait
des fautes à des décisions décisives si
ça fait pour la compagnie plus
profitable il faut de vouloir faire des
choix un produit de support qui a été à
un prix le moment là mais c'est ça qui
drague ce qui fait qu'on a des employés
super motivé par la mission c'était quoi
mettons les premières étapes le thé du
deal et y trouver la solution des
roulettes ça a été ce que tout change et
dont le
seco a lille les décisions clés ou
l'hymne les mouches clés qu'ils avaient
fait que récuse est passé de juste vous
devez couper cube à l'entreprise que
c'est aujourd'hui mettons l'artiste
avait des milestones à mes trois on a un
cas on a eu d'aller chercher le premier
distributeur alimentaire parce qu'à val
on ouvrait les épiceries puis on les
lions livrer les épiceries avec notre
tour il y avait j'avais un montant reste
un moment là qu'ils m'avaient dit donne
ça marche pas c'est pas une compagne
distribution et de production et c est
ce qu on peut nommer commentant
où ils préfèrent l'anonymat
oui
puis oui ça coûte un petit peu d'argent
et pivote reprendre des pourcentages
mais ça va te permettre de grossir fait
que ça a été pour le 31 01 ce bol puis
après ce point tournant numéro de jeu
7-6 7/2 mettons
à ce moment-là à peu près le japon deux
ans
c'était un mois à peu près de j'en ai
mis deux ans
et que les ai faites et qui n'ont su il
faut pas les laisser se fout des légumes
qu est-ce qui vous étiez encore à
sherbrooke on est tous nous ont produit
à saint-hyacinthe
l'incubateur alimentant la boc pour des
gens savent où se recentre fédéral ça
s'appelle le cerd et puis tu peux aller
un cube des entreprises alimentaires la
boucle que c'est un parc d'équipements
de je sais pas combien millions de tout
les équipements qui peut imaginer que tu
vas l'oeuvre collective d'une production
puis le syndic marty c'est louis puis ça
te permet de comme tester ton concept
marois qui a constamment cela on a fait
on en a fait 3-1 la boucle
donc tech les sociétés
anodine pour découvrir que cet endroit
les lycées a qui viennent place que
toutes les équipes que j'ai besoin juste
les bras lilou europe si je puis dire
une coupe et tout ça moi moi une bonne
un booster peuple ouais fait la
distribution ce qui mettrait le may doan
dessus je te dirai d'abord du
financement
on aime chercher du financement avec des
anges investisseurs dans la deuxième
année puis ce sera quand vous ça vous a
permis de faire quoi maintenant cet
investissement le cas chez nos premiers
employés et est d'abord comme un petit
souffle de faire comme acquis et non
plus comme avant c'est au lieu de
survivre ouais ce qui est un feeling
quand même
extrêmement télé de ses deux fils inc
ont le mans différents métiers incitera
et pour survivre la place de cette fois
bella allons de l'avant des grossistes
ont seulement c'est ouais ça ça a été
super et les employés les employés c'est
la mère de la guerre le tir d'ici le
juste me coltine que je peux aussi nous
écouter autrement tu peux me dire un
petit coucou yach le colis avait été
unie quelqu'un qu'on engage in que l'on
n'était pas vraiment capable d'engager
qui contemplait nécessairement le si on
garde nos états financiers comme commis
et elle met de langage et puis du fait
qu'ils soient vraiment ch ça nous a
vraiment permis de nous mettre notre
énergie ailleurs pu faire autre chose
cela nous permettait le justifier ça
faisait l'équivalent de couper cube dans
ce sens qu on venait ici c'est autre
coupé cube ces switchs et les cameron cc
comme j'aurais à être le parquet le
podcast fait puis mettons pas là tous
types à b le nikkei va péter saint
python qui aura ta façon quand je parle
puis guy nicolle mais la façade
qui n'est qu'à la fin
je sais que de parler puis c'est
satisfaisant ni même d'amnesty comme et
qui mais c'est quand même temps comme si
on met tout le temps qu'on met là dedans
dit pas en train de comme passer à la
prochaine affaire puis comme essayer de
trouver des solutions trouvées comme les
tickets qu'est-ce qui fera avancer le
truc qui constatent les échos qui comme
toi fou
la qualité de ton produit augmente
niccoli
merci
pour vos premiers employés
c'est quoi
c'était la première chose qu'on a besoin
de tous ceux là chose qui va faire cet
ep up les compagnies plus c'est
directeur marketing ont financé tout le
temps vu comme moi comme une marque ce
et puis on voulait développer la marque
puis les produits l'innovation pis c'est
ça finalement après quelques années on a
finalement identifié quoi éviter c'est
l'innovation puis la marque apple comme
sûre mais c'est vraiment ces deux volets
c'est là qu'ont été chercher de l'aide
dès le début kevin aubin je produisais
comme autant que je pourrai puis vint
est après celui des employés pour mettre
en production à la fin un tir de notre
épisode à saint-hyacinthe on était 25
employés de production si on voulait
jour soit on aurait pu rouler la nuit
est
ce que vous étiez ses camps dans tout ce
processus là vous en faites pas ce que
est ce que au début vous étiez quand
l'un on était juste en épicerie à
biarritz non c'est pas vrai on était
juste sur une page facebook pour en
ligne qui est la première programme is -
cardetti chez vous en moins bien précis
on a fait comme moi ça marche pas au
petit fallait livrer les sorties à
domicile seul et ça marchait pas plus
propos comme emballée sedan
on est tombé sur bourse en épicerie
pendant trois ans deux autres sources
quand même pour l'avoir déjà fait
rentrer à l'épicerie c'est quand même
costaud et le énorme parce qu'ils
imaginent nous aviez plusieurs chaînes
est ce que vous affichez des
indépendances et elle commence à
fonctionner c'était porte à porte au
début ça allait gagner d'aller voir un
épicier tu disais j'ai aussi mon produit
ce qui est merveilleux au québec qu'on
s'est rendu compte de ce qu'on espère
c'est qui au québec si tu veux tu peux
gagner important egypte si c'est très
son jeu s'est passé près comme notre le
monde veulent t'aider et puis un bep j
en prenais le produit 500 pages
que choisir qui nous dit on veut vendre
c'est certain que ce soit vrai partout
ce pauvre et à l'ontario aux états unis
oubli surf est qu ici on a cette chance
de comme ouvrir porte par porte tester
des affaires sans payer des frais de
listing s'en convaincre et laurence fait
que ce support puis on a fait ça on a
monté à jean 200% épicerie au québec ah
ouais juste en faisant du porte à des
lieux et on avait des distributeurs
aussi qu'elle qui nous est d'être
présent pour entrer à des places - -
puis après ça on a dit ok on se ment
dario enfin j'en ai on a fait la même
durée en ontario je voyage de toronto
avec clos tout le temps faisaient du
porte à porte on a trouvé un
distributeur fait ce travail et le
précédent robbie ci
est allé physiquement aux autres shows
ouvrir d ici
mais c'est un voyage on le fait moins
souvent puisque c'est un peu plus long
et que les vrais risso langouët
vous amenez vos rêves occupe dans la
soute à bagages pendant qu'on faisait
une bonne question parce que oui je
pense qu en les amenant bailliage
les gueux les gars qui regardent les
explique moi je pense c'est que c'est
possible c'est comme du site liquide
mais celui qui est congé lacasse
consentir et
[Musique]
puis dans tout c'est moi j'ai entendu
parler de vivre par le marketing
d'influencé vraiment lac gelé vu en
premier puis est-ce que vous ça a été
parce que de ma perception c'est quand
même un point charnière le quand vous
vous êtes rentré sur instagram puis sur
les collaborations avec des influenceurs
est ce que c'est un gros step comme moi
je les ai vus pour vous ou tout bien ses
sujets forts l'autre grosse tête pour
tourner attaqué son bateau c'est quand
qu'on a lancé à l'inpi cancun a lancé en
ligne on est heureux on circule ya trois
ans et demi
y'a pas assez sable trois amis parce que
c'est vendu congelé en ligne mais tous
deux nient avec quelques marques et
faisait au canada y avait des boucheries
à m kim aurait des boîtes à mes deux
piasses la vie pierre ce type mais il ya
trois lignes puis livré chez vous
personne faisait cette rencontre
effectivement je
sais pas si ça marche tous les fans
tchèques ont lancé matière en mode ont
testé le mon but mrv sujet de 200
clients je vois tu pas content parce que
je peux pour tester les nouveaux
produits avec eux on va comme avons une
espèce de petit focus group
mais finalement ça a vraiment décollé
justement comme ceux du péage à cause du
marketing de france puis de toutes les
affaires que ça nous ouvre être parce
que en épicerie c'est comme bouygues
plus forte au marketing du sens mais le
personnel voit puis comme faut toujours
vainqueur sans appel 3 jours hors cac
havas son épicerie fin octobre ending
soit vraiment vraiment distinctif et
leveaux qui est super beau le team
équipe derrière une porte de secours ils
sont en face parce que
décongeler c'est pas été qu'un petit
problème pour la section recherche
l'innovation la facture ça me permet de
sortir de ce
vraiment créer une connexion différend
avec le client
parce que je me rappelle moi si c'est
cependant un bon tu sais si c'est devenu
vraiment hot doll à mon fils puis avait
plus aucune façon que j'oublie que vive
exister c'est dans ce sens une fois une
fois que je l'avais vu
là à partir de ce moment là là je le
voyais derrière les portes le je le
voyais en épicerie puis le jeu l'a
acheté en épicerie ne tombe vite et vous
fait vraiment partie des 10 quelques
entreprises je m'entoure qui ont fait ce
choix lieu d'aller vers les réseaux
sociaux val andré le numérique le
rapidement maintenant l'outil avant bien
d'autres l'impression c'était
savez combien de temps on fait que c'est
la première fois que clowe a fait que je
pense chapeau parce qu'elle a eu
tellement une bonne édition dès le début
instagram était folle de nature à la
montée le comte pis ça c'est assez
dingue me facture
loin de ce que c'est aujourd'hui elle a
vraiment une bonne idée aussi des
claques ester à travers les utopies le
web doit utiliser les influenceurs salé
martic 6 allée à être par le xi est
rentré mettant dans cette demande russe
que
c'était en même temps c'est comme on
connaissait rien factice était juste
l'intuition sistep a jamais eu une
stratégie marketing beenie man
établissent des jambes impulsion pis moi
c'est ce qui fait défaut quand tu es
naïf je bosse a de fait les meilleurs et
ont allumé un résultat à la wii parce
que tu es en plus j'ai l'impression pour
la la clientèle que vous l'y rejoindre
que vous l'y rejoindre si comme le
meilleur canadien en moyenne - malte où
on est à un stade où le faux pas c'est
un peu différemment parce que l'on a
lancé aux états unis alain
fakty
puis extraire mais parce que c'était
avant il ya beaucoup de nos églises nos
partisans du taf on le faut comme à faut
prendre du recul ce qu'on a fait pendant
ces nuits c'est peut-être parce qu'il
faudra pour les six prochaines années un
petit peu de de nouvelles approches
marketing qu'on doit faire et puis
comment vous entrevoyez ces différentes
approches le parce que c'est quand même
c'est quand même c'est qu'en version à
se poser c'est une bonne question
vraiment de bonnes questions plutôt en
ce moment une des affaires que je tente
quand même de penser ces îles comme un
retour au vert
le contact physique pour l'épicerie
bible est le sampling puis
l'événementiel qu'il faut comme faux
comme profiter du fait qu'on est dans ce
district que les gens passent devant
nous fait comment tu fais pour créer un
contact à ce moment là qui est pas sur
le web parce que mardi moi ça c'est
cependant condamné le caecum faut faire
les deux formés faut revenir à créer des
contacts réels parce que
c'est ce pays comment tu sais que c'est
quoi la piste de solution pour bien
des choses c'est éloquent pour créer des
événements de dégustation de simples à
l'industrie en épicerie mais qu'on peut
aussi je sens
oui mais ça marchait tellement bien pour
nous parce que le monde est comme un c
dont petit pas juste une nous est le
saut les barres granola mais c'est pas
juste comme une ombre granuleux quels
membres - j'en ai g650 de même durée oui
sur l'univers des bandes son ensemble
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais non c'est ça marchait vraiment bien
planté on a pu on pourrait plus fort
pendant l'année 2010 quand on leur parle
on a plein d'idées comme soit pas placée
pour faire un enfant ne s'applique qu'à
des connexions real avec les jantes web
critiques vis à quand même hein
aujourd'hui c'est un genre de jeu trouve
les 4,6 quand tu penses à vivre tamarins
quand
on dirait qu tessala comme leur bien
être et leur santé leur ôter
les habitudes de ses mots d'habitudes de
vie qui comme mais comme je suis pour
red bull
le boulot leurs
commandes et des événements
comme
l'espace et red bull c'est comme créé le
limage meti a un peu le sentiment
d'appartenance ou si justement les
valeurs de pi
ben vous n'êtes qu'à vous faites bien
merci puis c'est notre défi c'est comme
comme un coupeur
comment qu'on peut continuer sur cette
voie là c'est le kit kat et trois
employés c'est facile tout ça hein pages
du quotidien 60 comment ces managers
puis clos si commun qu'on aligne tout le
monde masqué
marketing travaille sur la stratégie ni
comment qu'on garde quiconque s'y plient
marque qui on estime le plus les red
bull les nac et ont réussi la foire à
grande échelle rosas calais la lorraine
pied c'est sain c'est un beau défi mais
comme se dit surtout dans tes valeurs
qui nous le numéro un c'est bien être
numéro 1 des vives puis on veut partager
bien être via l'alimentation mais aussi
via des petites habitudes de vie tout
sauf acquise
tu parles de mettre tout le monde sur le
sur la même la même ligne même diapason
par rapport aux valeurs de l'entreprise
puis est ce que j'imagine que tu fais
référence ici autant aux
personnes qui prennent plus de décisions
que la personne qui fait le travail
manuel
robotique en guinée que tout le monde
soit sans même longueur d'onde
ça c'est
une coupe d'entrepreneurs sur le tueur
les ratios des podcasts que j'écoute
puis souvent ça revient de seppi
j'imagine que tu as dit que ça revient
souvent la culture d'entreprise
j'imagine que c'est parce que c'est
super intéressant mais petit miracle
comment toi tu trouves que ça s'articule
commente sauf ça se manifeste mais tant
qu ici tout le monde est sous même la
même longueur d'onde pourquoi aussi
c'est important et puis pourquoi si ces
importantes c'est quelqu'un qui fasse au
final un travail mais tombe un travail
d'entrée manuel a éliminé la même ligne
directrice que que la personne qui va
prendre les décisions marketing et on le
tue mais je peux parler de ma
perspective c'est là que je
perds mais pour moi c'est quitté au
début quand on a commencé on faisait
tout on était le service client on était
la comptabilité on n'est pas que c'était
facile comme que tout soit uniforme
quand on était 3 c'est comme je disais
tantôt seror facile puis 4 5 6 7 6 ces
contenants et toutes les messages font
du sens avec ce que toi tu ferais tu
comment toi tu le frère quand la voie à
claudia mettons guillaume d'introduire
ses larmes des vivres
moi je l'exécuté le
corps qui comme dit qu'il peut faire ce
que l'on veut
c'est carrément mais à quatre grossistes
et comme t'assurer que je peux dire que
le monde agirait comme claudia j'irai
mais oui c'est un peu statique hull la
façon qu'a parle la façon car les terres
agité quand ton équipe de vendre kaka
présente la marque qui est parle pas
juste du prime et ont quitté le suisse
l'exemple mais ça serait que des 30 40
50 60 employés de demain 2 senti qu'ils
soient tout autant demi ce message parce
que sinon la personne qui parle aux
clients et aux costumes services sis à
part l'an prochain gauche ou une paire
une coupe devant une marque ta personne
vendre qui parle d'une formation qui
joue supris qui disent quand on croira
quand on produit au cul par une coupe de
points de mark pauvre times est au plus
mal c'est vraiment bon
non mais jusqu'où ça parce que
effectivement que de le voir comme celui
de quelqu'un soins parce que l'exemple
mais tonton vendeurs qui qui parle de
prix à place de thé mettons dans
l'échelle des trucs que vous souhaitez
qui en met un en-avant de l'autre mais
juste là tu viens de perdre une coche
sur le message global je comprends ce
que tu veux aussi rendre s'est dit super
c'est que ce sens et pas à l'affût tu
sais pas
c'est
ma blonde a fait de la gestion des
réseaux sociaux puis c'est comme une des
choses
qui équipe comme le plus important pour
et théâtre avec plein de points de mark
le pitti com puis elle a maintenant être
au point justement qu'est le plusieurs
employés maintenant après avoir fait
tellement bien géré comme 12 brenda avec
son téléphone dans le thé et le
maintenant des langues pis c'est comme
la chose la plus importante qui
avec ses employés s'assurer que c'est
correct c'est comme est ce que le
langage est adaptée à chacun jack in the
brain ne sais pas ce que c'est des fois
on dit aussi elle a fait un post ou t'es
où puis c'est comme noms tels brain de
repos dix mots leur réponse aurait pas
utiliser cet onglet d'ajuster pour
chaque invité vous ôtez d'assurer que
tout le monde parle mais c'est une
personne qui parle mais c'est un blanc
n'est capable de créer ce pour les
marques de s'assurer de respecter la
voix d'un chapeau à m parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui est plus difficile pour
nous de travailler avec des agences
externes c'est super ça c'est nu avec un
emploi tu peux prendre le temps de
prendre des semaines pour y expliquer ce
qui est vive jamais en agence ou mentaux
pour cet art et surtout civile pour
faire formation face aux mêmes chapeaux
elle serait capable de respecter la voie
libre à bas ce sont ces propositions une
cinquième cas fait après le podcast faut
qu'on se parle de quelque chose que je
vient d'allumer
allumé ces questions ne faut pas
l'oublier je vous dirai pas non plus
quel bras les normes idéal fort de cet
atout
mais il ya quelque chose qui s'appelle
nick berg qui en compagnie de
de supplément de sport aux états unis
puis lui il vient il ya quand même eu ça
doit ressembler à peu près à une
centaine d'employés le ils viennent
payer 1 2 jours de formation par un
spécialiste de
2000 rands mission fait qui vient dans
l'équipe le sait tout le monde est payé
pour venir au bureau personnes
travaillent pilos et on se fait tous
formés à on fait des jeux des activités
d'affaires pour que tout le monde soit
capable de dire d'énoncer clairement la
mission de la compagnie et tout le monde
le dans dans l'entreprise d'autant le
silo lui que genre le gall entrepôts
tout le monde est payé pour venir
pendant deux jours se faire aider à
bild des suppléants mais clairement ça
m'a même pas joué ce soir c'est vraiment
sérieuse pour un malfrat qu'on fait que
probable c'est un suisse est là une fois
par an quand
[Rires]
j'allais passer sur notre faim les
autres ou dépassées vis mais aussi
maintenant servi
mais ça tout à des avis métier pour 4
puis leur camp a lancé d'autres lignes
de produits ben on se dit malheur ça
comme les temps ce qui est des d'autres
produits sur canal ça fait juste madames
a fait la
deuxième année j'en avais le plein
d'idées de trucs mais pour te faut que
ces manifs mais on a lancé les sous les
reports le on a d'autres choses qui
lançait l'année prochaine
mais dans le dans le pays cris makoun
sont des pâtisseries santé maintenant
que nous mettons en ligne oversea plein
de choses tant des concepts s'il est
toujours en ligne et des legends
préparer la nature senti que ça va être
happé d'avoir un pixar est abordable ça
va leur permettre de bien manger genre
mettant des des petites boules les
biscuits tu peux mettre une plaque
furent ceux chez vous ouais je sais bien
qu santé - peut-être pas mal d'ennuis
une vague on savoir non mais ça c'est ça
c'est pertinent en salle parce que moi
mettons faire des commencé à faire mes
discussions avec des dates ces longues
et pénibles vers ceux chez nous c'est
que c'est bon avec du grain de l'offre
d'eads à petit jardin d'une web du
beurre d'amande naturel gers est bon
sauf que commencer à les faire un stock
pour faire des deux semaines en été si
je n'avais pas tout le temps je mangerai
plus souvent un bon déjeuner tous les
soucis c'est un peu sorti en majorité
des gens vont prendre une fois deux fois
par semaine ils vont mettre le temps
matin un métier
c'est sa première est arrivée de la mort
à chaque jour parce que taux plein mais
traitable c'est simple mais au fond de
mon lit en effet qu'on veut on veut
attaquer d'autres catégories comme ceux
de remplacer un petit peu des fois le
show de code comprend un scrabble qu'on
comprend pour quelque chose de vraiment
santé ti qui a été aussi sympa mais qui
aussi 100 m c'est sûr que ça reste on
parlait des d'échelle dans tour pendant
le podcast avec marché là on parlait dé
celle de de valeur nutritive est reçue
ce temps maintenant picsou ventiler les
aliments sont tout le temps sur ce
passant même échelle avec de quoi qui
est vraiment beau prendre vraiment super
du temps fait que ça devrait marcher
de ce que tu parle depuis tantôt souvent
s'y était rapide bon pour la santé puis
abordable et puis j'ai l'impression que
c'est comme les trous clean s'applique à
tous les trois en même temps c'est comme
si ce qui est affirmé tandis que ça fait
un petit bout qu'on est normalement
temps c'est
la préservation des aliments
santé puis le mettre sur table j'espère
que ça durera une dizaine de besoin
quand tu es en épicerie c'est pour toute
la chaîne logistique
c'est vraiment vraiment complices pour
ça que tous les agents de conservation
qui met dans la conduite pas besoin de
rien c'est la meilleure façon de
préserver la nourriture mais le
conjuguer comme une mauvaise réputation
d'un coin 60 dernières années parce que
c'était comme la bouffe je peux pas dire
la marque mais c'est du vol est validé
le titre et petit pull up athlé santé
supprimant s'être fait que le congé est
en train de vivre une transformation le
puits on le voit petit on n'est pas les
seuls joueurs à la craie et mais qu' on
va utiliser congé pour amener la
meilleure alimentation un simple rapide
sur le marché puis ça va vraiment
changer beaucoup combiné prochaines
années à cause de soi parce que c'est un
potentiel énorme t'as pas besoin de
préservatifs 1 à 0 aucun besoin nous est
confuse et les plats avec vega n'est pas
plate
jusque là dedans on sait ce que ce que
le gars qui est qui avait pas ce qu'une
dose c'est sous vide comme quelqu'un qui
avait inventé cette technologie là nous
disait c'est qu'elle sait plus frais que
les légumes frais kt à l'épicerie parce
que aussitôt qu'ils sont prêts sont
congelés ils ont suivi de pierre si tu
veux juste les réchauffer c'est comme ça
c'est le plus frais que frêles d'enfants
aux effets de la littérature derrière ce
beaucoup parce que l'un des exemples
c'est le bleu et le blevec anc est
cueilli à partir du moment où j'écris il
ya comme une claque qui par un pilote
perd ses vitamines tranquille parce que
ça sexy mais quand tu achètes un bébé
congelé a été cueillie dans la même
journée a été sur joli mais ça ça en
capsules toutes les vitamines facteurs
soient comparées en bleu et
frais à l'épicerie que ça fait quand
même dans trois semaines que des cahiers
aux grecs ont juste retrouver des
niveaux de vitamine plus à vue d'un
congé c'est vrai avec certains fruits
les impôts la temporalité mais certains
fruits légumes
puis effectivement qui est congelé dix
mois les plats congelés que je mangeais
au secondaire le quand j'en mangeais
petite erreur le métis
t7 chipant tabac
fait que je peux comprendre il ya quand
même s'il est
nommé mark
lynas mais parce que j'avais pas dire ça
non mais un toit je peux comprendre que
trop
d'aliments
infectés
moi je me rappelle que ça c'est que ces
genres des frites arrière avec des
nuggets le caecum humides des gueux
pitié l'espèce de sauce brune pas clean
clean fait qu'effectivement il ya eu
quand même une mauvaise price la pile
est en train de renaître de ses cendres
selon moi le conjoint facture puis avec
les technologies comme tu parlais pour
le rendre encore meilleur au goût les
textos tout ça va vraiment vraiment
changé
tout est bleu s'étaient pas quelque
chose que tu
avais l'air frais c'est ce que j'ai
essayé j'ai trouvé ce fantastique
incroyable euros oui ils sont encore
d'ailleurs sondages en épicerie encore
je pense le
moment là bon la technologie est
incroyable le t71 melville est suivi
depuis c'est la même quelques coupures
berne sont maintenant aussi
c'est de la bombe
je veux qu on part un peu de
de ses loyers un petit peu de rythme
mais pour parler de l'entrepreneur de
l'entrepreneuriat puisqu'on parle depuis
tantôt si le minou est un sujet qui nous
est cher ici au sans fil si le sport est
comment le sport peut nous aider dans
notre dans notre vie dans notre travail
mettons le plan avant le podcast jeu
direct s'est entraîné pour 1 100 kg que
finalement tôt fait puis puis commet
plusieurs questions comment ç'a été cinq
lots deuxièmement comment est-ce que cet
entraînement l'autre peut concilier avec
ton travail d'entrepreneur comment
est-ce que ça peut aider août nuire si
jamais cette nuit dans ce travail de
bain les jeux je me concentre pour com1
la tête maintenant comme tous les
tickets achetés jusqu'au 10 par un peu
comme tout le monde j'ai des petits pas
de compétitions de haut niveau non il
s'occupe pas d'un groupe d'amitié des
jeux très bon mais comme jamais je me
suis dit je veux en faire quelque chose
de vraiment sérieux le sport c'est du
moins comme pour le plaisir toi quand
j'ai commencé vivre ça tout tomber j'ai
agi comme arrêt des transports
j'avais dit ça
mais ça va ma tombe et puis comme
j'ai eu un moment qui commettez un point
g j'avais été
j'avais recommencé à jouer au hockey amh
orient dans une ligue puis la première
game comme j'ai reçu de bain après comme
le premier chef chez comme vraiment
tordu mais comme étourdi gens malades
je pense que je fais une carence de
faire quelque chose ça doit être
fait max
tient plus et ça faisait un petit bout
qu'on était obligés vegan surface comme
en tête se met enfin que je m'en veux
prendre une prise de sang
je suis quand même en europe cher fois
de ma vie
complètement qui ça a été comme ça c'est
une réalisation parce que tu sais quand
tu es jeune tu penses pas sur le tg
tranché parce que tous les cours des
dieux et puis comment je bouge tout le
temps pour tout mais le 4 commence à
baisser
pendant deux trois ans à bouger par la
fonte cas précis je t'ai comme le j'ai
fait un commitment j'ai commencéà plus
courir je m'entraînais plus
régulièrement puis j'ai pas vraiment
marché ce depuis puis je me donne défi
chaque année l année passée je vais
courir 50 km on le fait cette année je
veux qu 1,5 km je les fais puis ça fait
partie vraiment de comme ma routine
bien-être le matin pour mon sport puis
puis est ce que tu as vu une différence
sur mes tontons
une acuité au travail et outils sur le
pastiche y ait beaucoup de monde qui
parle de deux problèmes solving
quelqu'un qui sont un ton dans l'eure
dans leur tête pendant le training
une réflexion en arrière pensée qui
suivait sur des sur des trucs dans leur
vie professionnelle passée la rupture a
de plus de mieux résoudre les problèmes
mais
ce que je vois comme souvent c'est le
mettons d'un derniers mois j'ai fait
j'ai perdu ma routine matinale de sport
puis-je devenu vraiment bourgon ah ouais
enfin à jour c'était plus bougons un
plus moi j'ai comme eu le flash la
semaine passée j'étais comme que c'est
qu'elle change de métier il bat les
affamés 61e monsieur j'ai agi reparti il
pleut je souris
[Rires]
pour toi
mais tu as des as et je me lève à 6h30
puis pas faire comme canadienne des
sports un petit peu de poids de la
course ou du vélo puis après ça un bon
déjeuner multivitamines bombarde au nom
par la journée
des classes entre sept pilotes au moment
de sport après six et demi
qui a passé ces partis à l'école
puis est ce que
c'est ça c'est sûr surtout
sur ta routine ton niveau d'énergie ton
humeur est ce que parce que moi je sais
que dans mes temps qu'un cas que
l'entrepreneuriat prend plus de place
dans ma tête des fois ça ne crée un peu
de stress ou d'anxiété outils de
juste d'un confort parce que c'est tout
le temps présent puis quand je vais
juste faire du sport ça s'évapore comme
un jardin ça disparaît c'est comme un
phoque mental qui sans vote qui me
permet de voir les affaires plus
lucidement ce que tout ça fait ça ou non
puis après ça aussi qu'on parle d'eux
est ce que
vous avez eu des périodes de stress
picamoles est sûrement moins mais je
pense je veux un peu comme toi quand tu
fais tu là bas c'est la course ne
mettent aussi fin qu'un jeu parcouru
c'est ma tête à commencer par spin avec
mes problèmes c'est ce qu'un soir je
n'aurais
fait non je pense que lui un peu comme
toi puis au niveau des métiers avec clos
c'est sûr que ça peut être un challenge
de ya pas de cooper c'est maintenant
challenge va falloir tout soit comme
changé depuis de money parce qu'on a un
bébé
c'est cela oui c'est bien plus fun par
les bep par jour je suis quand même faut
que je pas mal sur le travail même si je
t'ai maison phillips interruption pour
voir l'om s'appelle rythme loin mon
habit petits moments ensemble puis le
soir c'est le one time as we will be
king parce que moi pour avoir me lancer
en affaires un couple ne
recommanderais à personne vous aurez
commencé à l'été sur sa jamais creed pro
maintenance et ce pitch c'est dur de
dire
demain des recommandations at c ça peut
marcher pour tout le monde parce que
c'est pas vrai que ça peut marcher pour
tout le monde ça dépend des
personnalités que je pense que mon pic
l'eau ça faisait déjà six ans qu'on est
ensemble on se connaissait bien on est
tellement complémentaires c'est moi je
suis zéro maintenant brenda marketing
puis elle betty moins pas pour un mois
0,1 opérations mettant des vacances
compléter on avait chacun nous notre
puits
puis on n'est pas des tas est fort non
plus t on est comme bénin
puis est-ce que ses pairs c'est pour des
questions un peu un peu plus tôt mais
est ce qu'il a la bns a été source de
stress dans votre vie
j'imagine que vous l'avez vécu le
challenge après est-ce que plus c'est
gros plus ça avance
ce qui est percé ou non lieu c'est mieux
si c'est mieux dans ce sens où les wings
et les bonnes nouvelles les mauvaises
nouvelles du mercato commence troisième
année mais ça c'est moins en moins beau
exc des fois j'ai des wings et quand
vraiment cool mais si je pars pas je
sais pas si je compte à mes jeux
la chose qui va
non plus chaque c'est probablement moins
pire à un grossiste pas parce que dans
son système et on remet ça en
perspective de le faire sortir d'une
épicerie quand tu en as trop c'est le
tiers de ta business de faire sortir
d'une épicerie quand en eux mais c'est
ça mais c'est aussi que
c'est lé premier challenge qu'ont eu ces
genres et son livre à domicile puis le
la personnaliser je peux lâcher ce soir
premier à livrer ce genre c'est la fin
vie le système en vigueur le produit il
faut retourner demain alain prost et
jean c'était micro
puis au fil du temps elle est bâtie
auto - nicolita - les
qualités plus parce que c'est comme le
lit les glaces à fond d'alcool
c'est
très
[Musique]
[Rires]
fin qui s'attaquerait au menu tant mieux
ce même que je me sens piclo du double
avec la lhjmq est arrivé à laval j'ai
vraiment beau détachement aussi le deux
des victimes quand j'étais chez moi je
dis au sens positif dans son soutien se
laisse pas absorbé par les différents
mouvements en perspective les affaires
quand un enfant est vraiment bonne pour
comme vraiment faire la plonge et
d'infarctus est à kg puis penser aux
problèmes que tu as eu tes dents journée
est une championne ma coach ps qui
l'imaginent qui est justement le fait
d'avoir un enfant ça veut ça oblige à
déléguer plus le l'imaginable et j'ai un
petit peu moins présent tout le temps
est ce que est ce qu'ils avaient de la
difficulté à face ou est ce que c'est ce
que ça se fait bien puis vous avez comme
une confiance absolue un béti moi j'ai
eu la chance mais maintenant on a la
chance d'avoir une équipe au moment où
on a eu
one piece avait été trois ans plus tôt
s'arrêter
différent on n'aurait pas pu comme l'or
chez les mains du volant la clôture est
vraiment partir en congé de maternité
pendant un temps elle a vraiment tout
déléguer -
la manche compte travailler le reste par
un piquet oui mais oui il faut que faut
que je couche de laque de ce match là
dedans ce moment tu sais ça fait deux
mois et demi la facture j'ai vraiment
pas encore trouvé le bon le bon set up
mais
capté
[Musique]
fondateur est à la tête de l'entreprise
une fois j'ai réalisé que tu veux mais
moi j'ai une tendance des fois vouloir
un petit peu trop contrôler et rôle
informatif est que le ça l'était
l'épisode pour moi comme un gain faut
que les gars je laisse la place pour le
canada quand même
le
l'entrepreneuriat durable
c'est quelque chose que moi je me
questionne souvent pillé puis je les
fait beaucoup et je vais gagner pas
plate d'hermann en question certaines
d'avoir qu'on faisait parce que je me
disais crise on sent que c'est pas la
chose la plus durable au monde aux
autres je disais que vous l'êtes
carboneutre en 2023 est-ce que mettons
tout ce qui est
environnement c'est quelque chose parce
qu'on s'en passe quand même des découpes
de smoothie dans du plastique dans un
emballage de plastique tc c'est quoi
votre réflexion par rapport à ceux pis
puisque ça s'en va mais ton s'il ya des
des pistes le tir-passe qui est haram
est faux on n'a pas le choix de
consommer comme un con comme on consomme
avec les normes les choses qui existent
à notre portée de main avec un président
comme de faire la balance avec vous
évidemment qu'elle est au au marché zéro
déchet pire amenées tétons quelques
hommes ont parlé tantôt donc il des
dates pour faire ton dans ce multi le
matin jeux marine pour l'environnement
c'est mieux mais au final ceci c'est
quoi qui quoi t'es fait quel est votre
vision du land
l'entrepreneuriat durable la croissance
durable chérie je veux parler des trois
volets pas cet emballage on y mettrons
bien comprendre le volet on va commencer
avec emballage ouais t'es nous quand on
a fait le switch des cubes couper la
main vers la houlette une affaire que
met-on on s'est rendu compte qu'il y en
avait plus zéro perte plus aucune partie
les cubes devait tout
beaucoup beaucoup de pertes
sont ces dix à la salle soit bien pitié
pour le client aussi à la maison t'as
pas un fond du sac le continent gt et
tirait d'instinct fond du sac gourou
dessous de ce type qui calcule tout sur
le la perte alimentaire on a des mecs on
a fini par croire ce qu'on avait le
concept qui est qui permettait le misère
père aussi puis le c'est sûr ça va
arriver qu'on a une boîte qu'on livre
congé à domicile qui va comme on dit oui
il va toujours rester un petit peu de
pertes mais versus le ferai c'est
vraiment petit mal manger pire
on a lu beaucoup là dessus et puis on se
rend compte que c'est le plus gros fléau
de l'industrie alimentaire c'est la
merde parce que ce produit était monté à
la note est pendante a dû transporter
tout le fioul pour transporter tous
mécènes sur les épiceries petit finit
par lâcheté dans un mouvement il va dire
un paquet de méthane fait que cette
cession des volets qu'on a vraiment
vraiment acquiescé le truc là la perte
alimentaire soit au minimum puis on
pense qu'on a sans prétention mais on
pense qu'on a quelque chose de très très
dur avec les avec les sons du congelé au
niveau de l'emballage mais le plastique
en ce moment c'est l'emballage qui
permet de livrer notre produit dans son
intégrité au client on explore certaines
choses au niveau du compostables mais
encore le support croire que c'est que
c'est politiquement parce que d'une
chose par exemple qu'on essayait avec
nos copains compostables c'est qu'ils
ont léché fiemme le hip hop sa crosse le
persil quasi très très friable d'envoi
que tu réussis que le client un bout de
plastique concernant s'il y en a
plusieurs barria jeu cesa techniques
pour réaliser la vision compostables
petit monde ça fait longtemps que j'ai
cette vision de dire la bourse devrait
emballer comme des pelures de fruits
dans le futur ça devrait tout devrait
travailler comme des pelures d'orange
que tu fais jusqu'à me des barytons
aliments film étonnante en arrière
groupe que sa fille s'est remis à la
tâche je pense c'est là que ça va aller
ouvrir times mais pour n'est pas là
encore c'est en train de se passer c'est
en train de penser
chacun on y voit un morceau par morceau
comme nos idoles en tout cas qu'on a
lancé le web là dedans on s'est dit on
fait pas du web du foot maintenant du
sirop font ça qu'on la cherche et on a
trouvé un isolant fait ici
sbg leatherass baisse tous les noms
cités d
asbestos 2.0 puis un isolant fait en
chanvre pour les maisons on se dira tous
deux sont à le couper en panneaux pour
nos boîtes avec ce petit morceau par
morceau ou qu'on pourra aller chercher
le plus de matière comme éco responsable
on le fait fax et si le volet 1 pour
l'emballage volet 2 puis je parle aussi
de gaspillage alimentaire le volet trop
c'est au niveau de l'impact carbone pour
nous la façon qu'on regarde ça c'était
l'image que jusque je donne c'est
maintenant que se promène à la plage
puis ben blaque ball mais moi j'ai fait
un jour en colombie puis se promener sa
plage puis tu avais plein plastique
c'était vraiment l'enfer le stand le
j'ai vraiment katché le tout dans ces
pays d'olmes ya pas de système de
gestion plastique puis ça se retrouve
vraiment là aussi c'est comme si tu
prenais une bouteille d'eau sa plage
celle que tout votre garage dans l'eau
mais est on un paquet comme neutres
c'est la moindre des choses de la fin du
pacte et c'est un prince a battu lens
aboudou dans l'eau reste une rajoute un
problème au niveau du carbone on le voit
un truc comme ça on veut minimalement
commencé par être neutre c'est à dire
que ce qu'on aimait de par nos
opérations les compense puis nous on va
les compenser par la plantation d'arbres
chaque année on plante une forêt vif
pour compenser nos maçons carbone puis
éventuellement carbone même à un paquet
cet égard le
ccdh en excuse parce qu'un certain que
sa force et
ses décisions laisse quand même du
pendule
bien coupé à ton profil pour des raisons
qui sont bien évidemment
personnellement je trouve que c'est des
bonnes des bonnes raisons mais c'est
quand même une décision à prendre le
dessus quand même si des idoles pop se
situe toujours été dans votre dans votre
monde c'est de dire qu'on va s'écrire un
petit peu de profits pour
demander comment on fait je sais pas moi
qui cloua com on n'est pas des
comptables on a fait qu'on n'a jamais
vraiment bâti alors il faut toujours
capter chiffres là mais comme ça ça
jamais été maximisée devrait mettre une
question chez nous ce test est comme je
dis on sait même pas complètement de
voir si on est on est vraiment derrière
un projet avec et vivons n'est vraiment
leur mission puis on veut s'assurer de
le faire de la bonne façon tu verras que
je veux c'est donner une legacy company
s'est alloué montre à nos enfants qu'ils
soient comme quelque chose qui serait
pas fier
si on dirait que ça va ça vient aussi
avec tout les reste le dit quand qu'on
pense justement bien être comme la
valeur suprême ont très bien être mais
s'il passe ce respect de la nature de
l'environnement drire soit quelque chose
qui tu as aussi je serai comme curieux
qui mettons ça sur foule brandit
justement bien être santé psaumes et qui
se serait curieux
pitbull important pour la clientèle
vieillit c'est quand même quelque chose
qui des valeurs le titre fait que
quand l'acheteur pour les autres il ya
quand même l'impression qu'ils l'impact
et il peut pas dire ça sent bon sens
là vous rentrer aux états unis puis une
autre question
je sais les doubles hakas six mois
qu'une autre question que j'ai pas ce
que je
j'en parle avec des amis des gens autour
de moi d'autres entrepreneurs andréanne
marqué par exemple de wever qui veut
lancer une nouvelle chaîne de
cosmétiques c'est
une des questions que j'ai souvent s'il
est ce que ya une fin à la croissance
mais tombe bien parce que c'est vous
rentrer aux etats-unis + jeudi après
celui de plusieurs autres étapes le
d'améthyste c'est quand même un gros mot
via plusieurs jours d'étape gromov comme
ceux qui peuvent faire car emmener du
tram ans puis s'arrête jamais et puis tu
en rêves de tout ça parce que elle tient
justement à lens sans façon la chaîne de
cosmétiques et comme à fréjus avec dans
le fond sur judicieusement doublé dont
ton travail accompli ces faits qu est-ce
que vous autres comment toi tu vois
surtout si la croissance infinie est tu
il ya eu un moment où tu es belle que tu
me semble qu'on est juste si on ne l'est
pas complet qui va être rendu dans
l'ouest canadien et puis qu'est ce qui
fait qu'à amener à place d'être
satisfait rendu ans loos canadien de
stabilisons surpis rivaux qu'est ce qui
fait quand on est faible on va le state
puis le bain on va aller à
20,57 euros puis après ça on va aller en
europe ici ou qu'un message mais je vous
réponde cap assure vouloir connaître
votre réponse et les autres
mais je pense à des pas vraiment de
l'entreprise l'entrepreneur nou camp
qu'on a commencé vivre on avait écrit
sur un petit bout de papier on avait lu
le livre le secret
[Rires]
m notre vision de ce qu'est ce qu'on
veut à complet puis on avait dit qu'on
voulait on voulait être un succès au
canada puis aux états unis t'as pas plus
compliqué que ce que si on avait
totalement défini c'est fait pour nous
c'est genre ça il faut faut réussir au
canada puis aux états unis fait que ça
tout le temps un petit peu guidé notre
formation est assurée de bâtir une
marque au québec après ce retard yobi 6
puis l'objectif final a été déclinée en
plusieurs petites est exact c'est exact
mathis pas arrivé par hasard que manon
médias qui cette année on lance eau aux
états unis si c'était comme on attendait
le moment où qu'on serait mûr pour le
faire en fait ceci revient à la vision
de ce qu'est ce que tu t'identifies
comme le colza ligne d'arrivée la ligne
d'arrivée puis citant la pauvre
gosse que c'est quand même dur d'exister
pas un devant l'autre ou bête soit
peut-être comme comme tu dis juste comme
avant c'est sans vraiment savoir qu'un
arrêté puis prenez un prêt mais nous ne
ressentons pas mal de jus le type mandat
à accomplir un
bain mais ça tout à tous les pôles tous
les jours mais je me pose tout le temps
la question depuis jeudi on est loin
d'être dans une croissance
dans tout ce qu'on fait sauf que
sauf qu'à ramener j'imagine que c'est
une question de
ces camps ça commence à te faire chier
mais c'est quand c'est qu'un un dossier
que tu gères tu fais comme age me semble
je le gère épaules c'est un peu cela
rapporte qu'à me disais qu'un petit café
en ce moment c'est le parcours kaleme à
l'institut allemand importe le type ou
un papa de final n'est pas de faim parce
qu'en ce moment ce trajet l'oeil est
haute mais j'imagine que c'est quand il
y en a mais tu fais quelque chose comme
ça fait chier parce que c'est que c'est
trop grosse étiquette du monde qui
demande que tu veux pas nécessairement
travailler avec outils de la logistique
qui a team et ont traversé leur en
europe c'est plus qu'un a commencé à
travailler dans une usine que moi je
peux même plus à les voir à tout les
jours et les semaines ça me fait chier
non pacsés l'autre sens pour sa petite
tête du jeu s'absentait de marbé aussi
le team et ses cantates un certain
faouzi ben ton travail change beaucoup
mettons c'est moi c'est qu'en tant qu'un
des trois c'est vraiment différent de
claques qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
les choses que je fais dans la journée
sa part rapport le tri puis j'imagine
dans deux ans ça va être encore par
rapport à qu'il va peut-être à un stade
où jouer comme je n'ai pas ma job coin
peel la belle à ses deux enfants soit
que ben je me rends place puis qu'on les
vive continue d'avancer voir la vision
qu'on avait établi où je reste en place
puis on change un petit peu les
prochaines étapes mais je serai plus ce
genre à dire
le remplace par en place puisse
accomplir une mission à réaliser puis
faut que ça continue puisque sur les
tâches que j'aime pas pu jeter les
crédits torche qui exemple
mais ça
sera remplacé dans sa propre compagnie
sur la tête une bonne étape le pôle là
encore
c'est pour ça que souvent ces structures
les
bonnes personnes ouais on va on va te
remplacer tu as besoin dans une
rétroaction de quelque chose c'est pour
ce que dit que les structures avec un
board qui est en place avec les génies
externes qui peuvent amener un record
sur comme on était pas tellement bon ta
job sinon tu le vois c'est dur de le
voir j'imagine qu'une partie du plaisir
des skis drive si justement l'atteinte
d'objectifs l'ont utilisé c'est au début
ça a été un objectif depuis le début en
fait de rentrer aux etats-unis 6-2 face
au
puy entrepreneurs l'impression t
top russe ou le lephone notre sens un
peu ce qui drive le truc c'est comme
acquis que l'on ne réussisse on arrête
on atteint l'objectif qui est maintenant
on travaille pour le prochain c'est un
surplus qui pense c'est la nature
humaine ce2 commun de vouloir avancer
puis accomplir des choses puis si je
passe bien dans le sport je dirais que
c'est justement
l'objectif de jeu corps et 50 km couru
5km à qui on veut rentrer aux états unis
payer leur foncier
c'est la seule raison apparente et
apport de
permettant de partager ses bonnes
valeurs là de bien-être ou plus de gens
possible si ces participants doivent
c'est bon sauf que ça
reste pour atteindre un objectif parce
que si je sais c'est le fonds noté mais
les deux sont nécessaires puisque
maintenant je pense pas que
les challenges que je fais si je vendais
quelque chose que je crois pas à la
mission aurait donc moi je comprends
pour moi c'est sûr les deux vont à
minden mais donne moi ma personnalité de
mon support de l'émission qui pavera
masquer les bords du capot grandes
perspectives de croissance non pas
chercher le maire de dominique
pour moi ma patiente et jb dans les deux
chambres est ce que tu es vegan
aujourd'hui
salle le che comme trouvé mon régime à
ce moment qu'ils ont subis pas dans
sweet spot la maison les plans de baisse
avec clôt enfin que j'aimerais faire
l'épicerie c'est moi qui fait la magie
de la bouffe j'aime vraiment cuisiner je
m'érige cuisine pleine baisse mais j'ai
pu de deux cadres en règle c'est juste
que j'ai comme perdu le goût pour
certaines viandes mettons fin j'en mange
pas vraiment mais produits laitiers fgk
pas dans ma manger puis d'apprécier fait
que je trouve mon sweet spot - plaine
bay la maison peu après
selon vasco et le temps va se gâter
oui c'est ça ça me fait penser le fait
qu'ils gèlent et cette question est
peut-on être gelée oublié mais je veux
leur poser
au début je vais annoncer aux autres
choisis les toutes les recettes est ce
que c'est encore le cas
oui on est en équipe pour nous aider et
et à innover mais on est impliqué dans
tout ce qui est produits puis tim moins
c'est ce que j'aime le plus faire c'est
d'avoir des idées de qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait sortir et qui est équilibrée
affirme attendue des
marchés des systèmes comme sauf à coup
on est vraiment vraiment impliqué mais
quoi ses hôtes c'est cool c'est la
recherche développement c'est ce que
j'aimais le plus fort aussi mais
quelqu'un qui m'a dit le jour t'embauche
un
appel aux chefs des innovations pour que
tu penses délégués se d'accompagner dans
le trouble ah ouais ouais c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment durable c'est
ouais sûrement à moins que ça à dire
sûrement que ça devienne une espèce de
grosse forme et y mettons pas ça
steve jobs tim cook ils sont tellement
impliqué dans la rénovation des images
il imagine une compagnie comme se
quittent pas les fondateurs holy see you
qui sont impliqués dans le dans
l'innovation c'est même dur à trouver un
exemple on est vraiment compagnie c'est
que ce soit lui qui ait vraiment y'a pas
vraiment cuisine qui se piquait
les compagnies partie de vous au tpi ce
texte est un succès c'était comme une
vision plus de trouver quelqu'un qui
parfaitement en phase avec ses pieds qui
vous conseille d'aller dans la direction
qui réalise quasiment impossible ces
signaux mais pour moi cette semaine je
le vois les jeunes sortis goûter à dix
boutiques pire que se rappelle jacques
ont essayé les nouveaux produits genre
général tao plan les actifs en sorte
fondu il faut pour les bleus c'est quand
même hein on veut
vraiment travailler avec travail et les
recettes c'est vraiment cool expérience
assez coquette et vic ce bois est bien
là maintenant je suis en amont dans mon
bac bac es tu peux truc
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on souhaite
le d'en
vivre dans la vie avoue évidemment pour
la santé puis la jouer mais qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite dans un futur
rapproché à macau aux moyens longtemps
mais on est encore dans la tête dans
notre expansion aux états unis le jeu
par les verts un business team émeutes
ont cessé on est encore sur ce rêve le
de faire fonctionner un virus du nil on
a à peu près 500 épicerie d'abord on a
commencé on a une bonne communauté mais
tu sais si on est dans les débuts je me
sens comme si les industries états unis
s'est pas beaucoup le ballon le nombre
total des districts c'est pas juste
titre d'avoir les pieds c'est s'assurer
que le projet régisseur puis contre fait
qu'on est vraiment dans les débuts je me
sens comme quand on était au québec dans
l'année deux teams que tout est à fond
riffa qui fait que quand même le
sentiment de recommencer à zéro de
reconstruire de ces c'est dangereux
parce que quand on a commencé ici on
avait peur
ben on y allait vraiment avec
l'intuition et puis on était très
réactif ve le on arrive avec un bagage
dont des fonds pense savoir quoi faire
merci pour ce tacle non plus vous comme
enlever un petit peu votre apprentissage
que vous avez dirais c'est pas
pas même pays pas même un consommateur
afin que rentrer avec une humilité
d'être prêt vraiment réapprendre est ce
que vous vendez en ligne aussi les deux
puis est ce qui vous fait un peu la même
ma faute si tu me dis qu'il fallait
changer un peu la la manière de face
pour le marketing sommet ce qui
je travaille deux influences à la botte
à faire comme si vous aussi ça c'est un
petit peu tout ce qu'on faisait ici
pleut on a fait un essai aux états unis
plomb on y en a beaucoup d'apprentissage
l'année prochaine de qom ok il a froid
qui marchent pas comme si c'était les
différences mais t'en ben dehors faut
repenser comme un conte comment qu'on
présente la marque comme si la
proposition de valeur de rêver ikiss qui
fonctionne ici mettons
selon les mettons les valeurs
canadiennes québécoise s'est pas laissé
abattre le marché mettons deux mixages
même message a rejoint message rejoint
pas de la même façon ok le même client
fait la banque puis aussi c'est un
composé d'un territoire ya plus de
compétition doit taxer les positions de
vieux tu es compétiteur aussi fait qu
ils ont fait une stratégie de marque
vraiment de repartir à zéro puis pour ça
on avait besoin d'un oeil extérieur
rencontre avec une agence pour nous nous
ne nous donnait un oeil extérieur comme
acquis la marque est restée seule mais
le tarceva lui un petit peu mal pour que
ça résonne avec le client aux états unis
chaque hier au lendemain de ces monts
c'est mon grand rêve est intéressant de
sitka tchéquie et tcc c'est quoi la
différence la nati culturelle dans le
fond d'intrigué maquille on peut pas
juste mais même ici même même à
l'intérieur du québec de changer un peu
le message selon vous est ce que tu es
tu oui ton message ici en centre urbain
morial ça c'est facile de faire passer
de quoi devez gagner puis de la monture
d'eau courant là dessus mais si
t'arrives h coûte faut quand même que tu
supprimes sur un peu différemment du
passé oui 100 % ok le pied aux 2e et à
50 pays les enfants l'adorent n'obéit
fakir
ou tu commencer quoi les messages de
chaque et au fait qu' on a beaucoup
travaillé ce sera délicat fort ouais
millions divisé aussi on commence par 50
et petit à petit on commence vous
commenterez laquelle on a commencé dans
le nord-ouest puis en californie qui
concerne france et des créneaux succès
le puits après son fort
new york chaoui le shipping en
californie s'est faite sac à main ces
ressources ou pipi comment vous en voyez
vous même et vous produites tout tout
tout ce qui se vend ou les produits ici
ouais
j'suis besoin californie là c'est un peu
plus optimiste que son lancement soit on
produit six points on va descendre m un
troc de produits là bas plug ins entre
la boîte de distribution qui vont
emballer les bois que les clients comme
on en lit on cherche pas des boîtes
individuelles par tous les moyens
jusqu'à quel
étranger la torche
l'entrepôt de congélation exact le sait
maintenant un smoothie un yugi 3 samurai
4 octobre via semble surtout qui mets de
la glace sèche place et s'est livré dans
un rayon qui est quand même proche
autour du centre rex pour ce qu'on n'est
pas que c'est partout mais laquelle il
fournit que même le feu parce que le bus
200 deltreuil mais après sur les ours
entre dans le fond d'emballage labos qui
est un partenaire est visible qui
emballe et mes autres sas à savoir
n'avions jusque là un nom par trois qui
sont livrés par petits camions comme un
enfant félix non il va livrer la boîte
chez les clients autour non mais je veux
dire quand sa porte d'issy l'évêque
québec qu'elle fournit en truck de plus
6 à 10 décembre sachant pas
quand tu commences la beauce et sur sa
côte est
mais il faut que comprendre comment ses
hobbies si c'était la même chose mais
c'était quand même vraiment longue chine
foutait des quantités commun intéressant
pour sauver la pêche et surtout quand tu
commences talent du fait qu'il faut que
sauvegarder supporter
ton expansion de la beauté de demain ça
sera pas vraiment rentable pour les
premiers mots année mais
puis commande en ligne tous genres un
entrepôt la bofi capitaine commandes
depuis non non moi je suis assez cool
ça c'est
vraiment ça fitte là
les valeurs vives qui raisonne plus en
californie où m au nord-est où regard on
est encore dans cette découverte c'est
quoi les messages qu'on raisonne plus en
qu'elle fournit versus nom reste en ce
moment
ouais mais ça lui a dit qu'elle fournit
je pense qu'en fait juste pas comme
j'étais au niveau du message et je pense
qu'on est juste pas de gens comme toi
qu'elle fournit fakih une récente
travail de marc à faire pour vraiment
dit ok on voit qu'on va pouvoir entrer
la beauce
et
ses primes au kindle qui est lui pensé
changer ses canettes pour un autre
brenda selon layton halfway pour genre
se positionner vraiment dans la
compétition le avec un branding qui
popent pour ce que les gens dansent et
on le consomme ce qui vole que participe
à la même chose partout comme secrète
sachant quand même que
c'est ça sinon votre question parce que
de sion
même si mais c'est cool c'est tout le
fun de voir justement que c'est fait
avec quartier avec quelque chose que
c'est un parti toptable ont quelque
chose de beau là dedans c'est de cesser
bosser pour être littérale baby ce que
vous avez fait votre premier bébé
un projet de site où le temps restait
justement et il l'aura vivons sans qui
est encore bien le haut qui présente pie
que
6% accor fait avec car même si sida même
si l'expression fait partie du genre du
portrait l'individu du but et
chapeau même si on va attendre avec
attention les morphèmes biscuits ou et
des choses qu'on sait pas encore
exactement mais merci beaucoup d'être
venu c'est super c'était vraiment une
belle diction metz ligue
2 du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le patriote le pitch vous abonner
pour trop dollars par mois c'est trop de
longs mois et trois pièces par l'as par
mois et vous avez les podcasts en avance
xavier premier de votre groupe d'amis a
recruté les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tuer le la dynamique entre
les amuse tout le temps avons une avance
sur les jobs en avance je rentre de toi
mais avec pétillante en avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que le ch et le podcast unis voulu
nous en dire davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast mec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on vend jaser on va
t'il et nicole non on y colle il est
maintenant évident comme un fils
travaille la place travot détaillé le
mets en jason par la conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pékin il faut s'abonner abonnez vous